lyon c'est 500 caméras pour cinq cent
mille habitants voyez un petit peu la
différence donc je crois qu'il ya une
vraie volonté idéologique à lyon c'est
quand même le résultat de la gestion de
l'ancien ministre de l'intérieur d'alors
s'est pas inintéressant de voir que il
n'avait pas beaucoup développé social de
vidéoprotection aujourd'hui avoir encore
au moment où nous parlons des débats sur
la vidéoprotection je trouve ça moyen
âgeux comme si on ne reconnaissait pas
assez tout ll aujourd'hui le corollaire
indispensable à l'action des forces de
l'ordre ça ne garantit sa garantie
toutes les libertés publiques
les images sont écrasés au bout de 15
jours quiconque n'a rien à se reprocher
n'a aucun risque de se balader dans le
champ de vision d'une caméra donc nous
on continue alors soyons bien clair il
faut aussi peut-être qu'on soit un peu
plus aidé c'est pas le problème du maire
de lyon mon collègue maire de lyon et
contre la vidéoprotection c'est pas un
problème financier sinon il devrait
trouver les crédits mais je pense que
l'état pour être un peu plus en support
des collectivités territoriales pour
financer le développement de la
vidéoprotection les régions le sont
d'ailleurs laurent wauquiez président de
valrhona avait proposé de cofinancer à
la duchère un système de protection donc
on voit bien qu'il ya une magie un
blocage il ya un blocage idéologique
complet de gens qui ne veulent pas voir
qu'à la criminalité et que la
vidéoprotection peut nous aider mais
donc il faut débloquer ce blocage la qui
n'est que politique le maire de lyon
fait de la politique sur le dos de la
sécurité de ses concitoyens que la
moitié des peines de prison dans ce pays
ne sont pas exécutées six mois après le
prononcé des peines parce que nous
n'avons pas assez de places de prison et
vous ne pouvez pas demander à des
policiers et le font d'ailleurs avec
beaucoup de courage et on a vu encore
les tirs parce qu'ils ont essuyé hier à
lyon vous pouvez pas demander les
policiers d'être tout le temps sur le
terrain de démanteler si au bout de la
chaîne il n'y a pas un juge qui dit ça
sera la prison et ça c'est d'autres
points faibles en france aujourd'hui
vous savez la main car series temps vous
savez quand même la partie ça qui
s'annonce chaud pour trafic de stups
vous savez vous oui j'en ai une pas très
loin de chez moi j'ai déjà visité chose
en
remerciant je veux simplement vous dire
une chose c'est seulement aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui la justice est beaucoup trop
laxiste beaucoup trop laxistes sur les
trafics de drogue et aux policiers de
faire le boulot des juges il faut que
les dos d'âne à this is vous